the word thought leader was coined in
1994 by a gentleman named Joel Kurtzman
and originally it applied to someone
whose ideas merited attention these days
thought leadership in some ways has
become an overused term some people
claim it for themselves and say I'm a
thought leader in this I'm a thought
leader in that and so as a result
sometimes people are a little allergic
to the terminology and think that no one
really is a thought leader but I
actually believe it's a worthy term and
a worthy goal because what we're talking
about is something very distinct from
either celebrity or expertise if you are
a celebrity that's really just about
Fame you're just known sometimes you're
just known for being known if you were a
thought leader it is about your ideas
you are known for your ideas which is
far more valuable to society and an
expert that's a great thing to be it
means you know your stuff you're
knowledgeable but if you're a thought
leader it means you have to have
followers it means you are engaging in
the world and that means your ideas are
going to have far more impact some
people think that they can't have a big
idea they can't be a thought leader
because everything's already been done
they have an idea but somebody else got
there first
the truth is every idea has already been
taken that is no excuse not to do
something about it
I write business books and if you take a
business book and you distill it down
into a one-page summary every single
piece of advice in every single business
book can fit on a note card and is going
to look something like the key to
networking is being nice to people or
the key to being a good manager is to
listen these are things that are not
rocket science but yet there are things
that too many people don't know and
there are things that in a lot of ways
we are not ever gonna really be able to
fully understand unless we hear it
properly with an open heart and an open
mind and the way that you do that is
through stories and anecdotes
that you here and by something being
conveyed from a particular perspective
you have something unique to offer by
dint of who you are even if something in
theory has been done before it hasn't
been done by you in the way that you can
do it it's time to step forward and to
recognize that you can make a
contribution